منذ بدايه العام والتظاهرات في اسرائيل لم
تهدا ضد خطه نتنياهو والتي يسميها اصلاحا
قضائيا
ورغم ان نتنياهو قرر ارجاء التصويت على
خطته وفتح الباب للحوار الا ان الكثيرين
لم يصدقونه وظلوا في الشارع يتظاهرون
للمطالبه بالغاء الخطه برمتها وليس فقط
ارجاء التصويت عليها
يعني الغاء القرار نحن نريد منه ان يلغي
قراره وان يجلس معنا ونضع خطه لكي نتمكن
من العيش سويا سواء كنا عرب او يهود او
بدو او مسلمين او اوروبيين جميعا يجب ان
نعيش في سلام وديمقراطيه وهو يحاول ان
يدمرنا لذلك نحن هنا وسننجح
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل ان مناصرين لنتنياهو هو بعض
الاحزاب اليمنيه المتطرفه باتهم ايضا
ينزلون الى الشارع لمطالبه على قراره وعدم
التراجع ما يعني ان صدام الشعبي الداخلي
في اسرائيل بات امرا واردا اكثر من اي وقت
مضى من مدينه تل ابيب عبد الحفيظ جعوان
العربيه